uh i'm don wibbie i'm from holland i'm
actually a technical evangelist with
devexpress and uh yeah devexpress
obviously does some stuff with blazer as
well
um yeah and i thought i'll give you an
introduction on a specific topic on
front end development which is state
management
i don't have a lot of slides
because we're going to do a bit of
coding and checking out a couple of
things by example that makes more sense
i guess
um
yeah so obviously the first uh
the first thing is why would we use
state management well obviously we're
working with a single page application
and if you compare that with the
traditional web development like uh mvc
or
razer pages that kind of stuff yeah
there is like a different way of
keeping your ui in sync and with blazer
we can do some really cool stuff
obviously
so
just to get an impression who of you is
already doing blazer developments
and the rest is looking into it
or like
yeah okay cool
all right so this will actually be my
first blazer session without going over
the introduction of blazer so that i can
finally skip that
and the examples that i will be showing
will be both applied for blazer server
as well as blazer web assembly
yeah so as i mentioned we're building a
single place application so basically
everything runs in that same page and
it is a component-based ui so you want
to make other components maybe yeah
depend on data which is uh all across
the application so how can we manage
that
and the other way the other thing which
is very important with single page
application development is how much
state do you want to have on the client
okay so
i mean a typical use case would be like
okay i've got this shopping application
and i want to keep track of the shopping
basket that might be state
but at the other end
you might want to have that shopping
basket on the server as well so you can
do some analysis later on on people that
did put something in the basket but
didn't check it out so
you have to be
thinking about it very thoroughly like
what do i want to keep on the client and
what do i still want to post back on the
server or maybe you can do something in
between
and there are various ways
yeah to maintain state and to let other
components know
that some state has changed
and for this i will at least discuss
three techniques on how to do state
management
if time permits i have another one but i
will guide you through that because it's
a bit more complicated and i will not be
doing the live coding stuff because you
will get lost anyway it's a bit more
work but the idea itself is quite nice
okay so the first one that we're going
to talk about is well let me first
i put together a small demo application
and to
give you
a bit of another
application i obviously use the
starter project
that we have at devexpress so you've got
another thing as the default microsoft
look and feel yeah but typically yeah
it's the same
well
the first thing i'm going to show you so
what can you do with state management
well for instance if i go to the grid
i have adjusted this slightly so i have
this data which is shown in a grid
and the temperature is shown in
fahrenheit can anybody can all of you
see this or should i zoom in it's a bit
small but
what i also did i put on a couple of
time stamps which we will see a bit
later to see when something is rendered
and when it's not i had to have yeah so
you can actually see the impact on
certain decisions on state management
so what i did put on a button
if i hit the button it will toggle
and it will show the temperature in
celsius the celsius was also in the data
feed but it's more like okay
the button is green now so we can
actually see that we have done something
if yeah
state management is all about if i go
back to another page
and i go back to this one
state is lost of that fahrenheit
first celsius thing right
so how can we
maintain that throughout the life cycle
of the application that's that's the
whole idea
well
[Music]
if i switch over to visual studio
i have set up a couple of uh
of things here and i've put in a bit of
code
i mean
this is typically standard standard
stuff i'm injecting the forecast surface
and uh
i put in that button
i put in a couple of properties
to
make sure that i can toggle the button
so this is
not really rocket science but what we
basically want to do is in this case the
show celsius
property we want to keep track of that
state
and so the first thing i'll try to keep
in sync with my slide deck
is
we're gonna use the cascading state
parameter this is this is typically a
thing which is
yeah
really easy and very nice implemented in
the blazer framework and it is also
quite yeah easy to use
so
how does this work well
let's let's start by uh creating
i've already created it but let's let's
start with a new
in this case my cascading state control
this is just a razor component basically
and i
i will put in a number of things here
which is at first
the cascading
element here
the cascading value this is a very
important thing and what this actually
means that we will create a component
which doesn't have anything visible
it is a component it will be rendered
out by blazer
but it doesn't well it basically
shows one thing and that's the component
which is inside this render fragment
yeah so typically it's like a
non-visible container
if i want to use this
i can go to for instance my app razer
file
and
this the abrasive file is the main
component hosting your entire
application and i can now
embed
this component the router component it's
also a component
i can embed that one
in the my
cascading state
and as i said the cascading state
doesn't have any properties yet
but it's just there
and if you would take a look on how your
application would render it will
instantiate the my cascading state
component
inside the cascading state component
there will be the router with all the
bells and whistles and your application
basically runs inside that my cascading
state so if you switch
fuse or whatsoever
that my cascading state component will
be the same one it will not be
re-rendered because everything is
happening inside that thing
so what we can do now is
if i switch back to this control i can
now add
properties
to this component
and in this case i have
put in a boolean show celsius which will
maintain my state whether i was looking
at it at celsius or fahrenheit
and more important what i did i
the setter of this property i have
checked whether that value is changing
and if it is changing i will also set
the new value
but more important i have
triggered a state has changed which will
make your blazer application re-render
basically
so you might think like hey it's going
to re-render like the whole thing that
might not be very cool because this is
like the root component but we'll see in
a minute why i written down those
timestamps under the portions of the
application
right so now this is actually
maintaining my state for my show celsius
if i now go
to
one of my second pages here
this is typically a copy
of the the other one
but i made a couple of changes here
uh and i'm gonna add a couple of more
things here as well
so one of the things that i need to do
here is
instead of using
the components and the properties inside
this control let me comment these ones
out so
i won't get into trouble here
[Music]
this is typically
the magic
on how this cascading state will work
so as soon
as i declare a property inside my
control which i decorate with the
cascading parameter and because it is of
the type my cascading state
blazer will make sure that i i need a
reference to that cascading state
component which was my root component so
blazer will will make sure that it gets
like
available here it's like a bit like
injected but
different you know the reference of my
state is available now i don't need to
do anything for it
and what i
for the rest what i changed here
instead of using that local property on
the other page i am now using the
mystate.show celsius
okay so i blazer will take care that
that state thing is available here and
now i can just read and write those
properties so i have passed in that
reference to that component which is
really simple to do and it works
really well
there is one thing that i do need to
change in this little demo and that is
the columns
that needs to be toggled
and so obviously i hard-coded this
so what i now can do is uh this is the
fahrenheit so i can now just bind this
i need to do it like this not my state
dot show celsius
and the visibility of this column
and
i can make this one my state dot show
celsius
so now i'll be able to toggle those
columns which is what i did in the in
the initial demo as well
one of the other things that i need to
do is i
will obviously need to code this event
as well i commented out so the demo
would build
the toggle temp click will just change
the value here so
but now on the my state component so
typically there is a couple of things
that have been changed
and
if the
hot reload works let's just give that a
go
there is
visual not really a lot of changes but
there is one one important change
obviously that we want to see
and that is uh if i will go to the grid
two
and i hit the show celsius
we'll see that everything toggles nicely
still but if i go to one of the other
pages and i go back to this one
you'll see that the state has been
maintained
so one of the other things that we could
do is okay so once we have this
component i mean the state is being
tracked now but how can i make other
components be aware of that as well
well with this approach that's extremely
simple
so let's
let's put up on the on the right top i'm
going to put in a control
that has like this little slider button
which allows me to change the state as
well
right
so for that i have already
prepped some stuff as well and
let's
see if i would go to
that was
yeah this one
what i'll do
obviously
i'm using the dev express checkbox
and
i am also
using the same approach so i am
declaring this cascading parameter
and blazer will make sure that same
component will be
available here and now on the check
changed i can just
yeah change that
thing inside that root component
and if we want to have this available
i'll need to put that in here
let me first save that one and go to the
header
i put it in here
and this was the menu
toggler
control
like this
so basically this control that i just
built doesn't have any direct
relationship with the control containing
the data grid and the button to toggle
the visible the
the temperature scale
yeah but if i would now go
to my page what we'll see on the top is
we have the slider
and i can
still i can toggle that
and what you'll see is
still the button
toggles correctly
as well as the temperature and i can
also do it like here
yeah so you'll you saw the slider go the
other way as well the cool
the cool thing is even that if i go to
this page and i toggle that button
and i go back to the grid
it's still up to date
and now
it makes sense why i rented out those
timestamps because i did like a full
state change to remember in that root
component but what you'll notice is that
if you check out the navigation menu
it's got like 22 seconds and that one is
on nine and the other one is on six so
if i would change
that state
there is like going to be a new invoke
state changed
but what you'll see is that
that one didn't re-render
that one did and obviously that one did
as well so this is obviously one of the
very cool things with blazer that
synchronization or what needs to be
re-rendered is quite cool
and so you don't need to worry too much
about that if there are components on
your page which do not involve that
particular state it will just not be
re-rendered
so
this is this is a very simple and
effective thing to maintain state for
for certain things
all right so there is there is another
approach which uh
which is a bit more you you could
actually
do
a bit more fine-grained control on what
needs to be notified or update with it
and that is yeah it's typically like by
using a state machine
what is the state machine well that is
basically
some object which lives in your
application
and
that keeps track of the state
well and because
dot-net core and blazer they have an
excellent dependency injection mechanism
we can actually use dependency injection
to register a singleton or scoped
instance and inject it everywhere
so that's the second approach i'm going
to show you
and how does that work well
i just told you but let's let's go into
that anyway
i have created a class here
and this class is just a class basically
um
i am declaring this this show celsius
property what is important or more or
less like a convention and not to make
it like too complicated to find bugs and
stuff
it is
yeah the idea to have the show celsius
property to be like a read only property
yeah so that's why i put in the private
set i don't want
this component to like directly change
that property because that might cause
any side effects on all the controls
that i'm not aware of and that could
cause like issues
and so the idea with like a state
machine is we have this read-only
property that we can read so we can
actually bind the value of this property
to like certain elements on your
components
and
what i also do i have declared a
an event
and in case that show celsius changed
i'll fire that event
i'll have a private method which will
notify this which will actually fire up
that event in case it's necessary
and
the next thing i'll do is
a
method which will actually change
the value so i need to call this method
to change the value and this is more
like a guideline and and typically with
with these kind of approaches you'll
return the old value
okay so if the property was false that's
going to be the return value of this
method
and you pass in true so the state will
change and you'll get the old value back
if you want to do something with it or
not but it's more like a convention
but what i also do is that you see that
i will check whether that value has
changed and if it has changed and i'll
notify the show sales is changed i'll
fire that event
so
and instead of doing like a component
i'll put in a component somewhere what
i'll do now is i need to register
this this object uh in the dependency
injection
and uh yeah that is that is quite
straightforward obviously so i can now
just say
dot builder.services.add
here is obviously one thing that you
should be aware of
if you're doing blazer server or you do
the lifetimes
with blazer server are slightly
different as with blazer web assembly
so if you would register this on blazer
server as being a singleton
if i hit that button
eventually you will see it in the same
thing as well because that state lives
on the server and it's a singleton on
the server
so the safest way with this approach is
to go for the scoped
a scoped
surface is
for the lifetime of one use or so that
is basically a singleton on the user
webassembly doesn't have the concept of
scoped so on webassembly it will be a
singleton and that will be correct
because
you're the only one on your webassembly
thing
right so that's an important thing and
the safest way to to get started is to
use the
the scoped one
well
normally you would
do like an interface and declare it like
officially but in this case this is
going to be my state and it's all
fine with me
i do have another session on dependency
injection but
so i'll save you those details right now
all right so i have now done that i can
now go
to my
third second example and which is
basically
a copy from that first page
yeah
but there is one interesting thing here
so i am injecting this state
and the state is again not a component
but it is just some data structure and
there is an important thing because i
want to to bind that event the notify
changed
you need to
implement the idisposable
then i will copy in
the same kind of stuff that you've seen
before but now i will insert some
slightly different code i'll go over
that
here
so the first thing that i have done well
this is basically the same but now that
my state is obviously being injected so
it's not the cascading thing anymore but
now it's that object so those references
are pretty much the same
but what i did do is that i am actually
calling this my state dot sets show
celsius and i'll change the state like
this
and
the other thing that i do is i have
coded
that event so in case the show celsius
changed i do a state has changed
right
and then on the un initialized you can
just do this on the on initialize the
async one won't be necessary because it
is uh just a declaration here
i am binding the event and i need to
unbind that event as well that's why i
was implementing the eye disposable so
if the control has been rendered it's
done it needs to like
remove the event handler otherwise
you'll get like memory issues and so on
yeah so i with this in place we have
typically done the same we have the same
behavior but on a different approach
yeah so if we also want to update the
slider i've created uh
a copy of that control as well so let me
also implement the i disposable for this
as well because we're going to buy that
event
and
with this in place
we pretty much have the same
declarations you saw before
and on the code i will
code in that show celsius changed
and i bind it on the on initialize and i
unbind it on the disposed so it's a bit
more code but you can actually
yeah fine-grain the updates because if
you have more
properties in that state object
you could decide to create events for
certain elements if certain data changes
you can fire one of those events or you
can do it for for everything
but with this approach you have a bit
more control over
which
updates needs to be done somewhere
if i have
done it all correctly i can now
show you the third way
or the second way
where is it again yeah so again we have
a
show celsius this time i have changed it
into a red button
to make sure that we're on like another
page and again
it changes
but
the other one didn't change
the slider on top and that's obviously
because i forgot to change that well i
didn't forget it but i was just showing
you like
so yeah the only thing we need to change
in the application is that we need to
change the reference to the header
in the header as well so we need to to
pick that other control
which was the
srv i think
and now
we have the same behavior
you see
so still the components are not aware of
each other but they're still able to be
synchronized throughout this mechanism
as a result we can take this one a bit
further down the road i mean this state
machine kind of approach we could also
go for like another approach which is
the
good old
mvvm pattern which
lands itself excellent with blazer
it does depend a bit on the amount of of
complexity that you want to put in your
application and
but i mean yeah with the mvvm pattern we
will actually separate
the logic in the ui completely
from the razor file and put it like in a
a class and we can use dependency
injection
and use that same fuel model
to store the state
that's that's one of the other things
that we can do and i mean for certain
scenarios it might be nice to use the
mvvm pattern but you have to decide that
from the start of your application
because it's like you have to go
all the way basically
so how does that work well
again i have
prepped some stuff here and uh for that
we are going um into the
i've set up a folder here which is few
models
the view model is basically
the class that contains
everything state as well as logic
business logic if i click a button it
will happen inside this
this model
and to do it correctly i've already
implemented a
and i've declared an interface for it as
well
and i have
the fuel model
i have taken this a step further because
i also decided that i would use
dependency injection to just inject that
weather forecast surface completely into
this
fuel model as well why not
and i could actually store a copy
of that weather
collection as well maybe that's
something you want as well
so this is this is a step further
i furthermore more put in a couple of
things like does it have any data
i have put in some logic this is
typically something you you will need in
a few model which is like some sort of
an initialize so if
if you go to this particular page for
the first time that model will be
instantiated it will do certain things
but if you go again you go away from
that page you go to another one and you
go back
you might want to re-initialize certain
things so it is always a good way to
have like some sort of an initialized
method which in this case will re-fetch
the data
if the data is empty
and one of the other things which is
important is that
you this this view model
can't directly trigger a state change
like the ui has been updated
so for that you would
typically need something like a trigger
state change which is
more or less in the same direction as i
used with the state machine
and so like the notify state changed
for the rest i also put all the logic
concerning the button text
the button style show fahrenheit is this
and i put all the logic and all the data
that is related to that particular page
i put it in here
i also put in that event that state
changed
and the trigger state change method
okay so typically everything codewise is
in there
if i now
uh
i now need to register this with the di
as well
so for this i will actually go the same
approach so i will do a builder dot
services
dot
add scoped
and now i can do that officially like i
uh what was that thing again great view
model
grit fuel model
okay
i'll stop that
so how does this work in the uh
in the actual components
well that's quite straightforward it
will also because we need to bind that
event to handle the state changed
um we can now uh implement the dispose
of the eye disposable as well because we
need to bind it and we need to unbind it
once that control is done
and
for this what i'll do is i will use the
inject direct directive to inject a fuel
model instance into this component
well the rest is pretty much
what you already saw and so instead of
now using that that other state
mechanisms i am now directly using that
fuel model
and i'm using the forecast as well this
is a bit different from the other ones
but for the rest
we have
still the same things going on so i have
now the few models show fahrenheit fuel
models show celsius so basically
bind as much stuff as possible to the
view model that's the whole idea about
that
now there is only a slightly bit of code
involved
and that is typically
i've even compacted the methods to make
it even look less
the state change triggered is going to
do the state changed the initialize will
bind the event and it will call the
initialize well you could imagine that
you can actually create like a base
component like a generic one where you
pass in the view model type
and you don't even have this code in
your your own classes you can make that
very easily
and then on the dispose we'll unbind
that that state change event
well if we want to apply this on this
slider button as well
which was that different control well i
put it in here as well and
what i basically do is i inject i still
do the same thing so i will
implement the eye disposable i'll inject
the fuel model that will be the same
instance
and
i do the same except that i'm now using
the viewmodel
method here as well and one thing that
you should try not to do if you have
like an event handler with a button or
whatever it normally comes with event
arguments
stuff like that you typically don't want
to have that in the view model method so
it's
shouldn't be necessary there
and then we'll bind the event
and uh
we trigger the state has changed well
and in this case the state has changed
will only apply on that control now and
the other status change from the grid
will apply on that one okay so that's
that's basically how that how that works
so if i would now run it it will give me
a small error let me see what did i miss
here
i would
miss out on this yeah
i was just checking how you were doing
all right so
this will
this will result obviously in the same
in the same
effect as we used to have but we do have
less code in the eraser file which i
personally like a lot
yeah i mean we all know the the the
winform stories with like
event handlers and like gazillion lines
of code while the application was
expanding and here you will keep that
separation
really really nice
and with this in place i did not change
that thing on top
and now i actually did forget it
but let me quickly
put this one in
m
v v m
like this
all right so now i have changed the
buttons again and what you'll see is
that this will actually work
the exact same way
yeah so this is a third approach of
maintaining that state and you can
imagine that you can have stayed now
with the mvvm approach you can have
different view models which will
maintain different sorts of states
because it depends on the functionality
of your ui
you can also use a combination of of all
of them yeah i mean you can have like
this state machine being injected in one
of the few models and still have access
to
globally available data
so you can combine that
all right so
yeah we have time for another one and
is there any of you because this is a
bit of a complex one and i mean
i just love the way it works but you
should be
very aware of
if you really need it i mean it's quite
a bit of work
but it's it's a nice idea but let's let
me ask you guys who of you is also doing
react development or angular
okay yeah okay
so the last thing i'm going to explain
to you is
then probably something that you are
already aware of which is the flux
pattern
i mean particularly with react it pretty
much comes out of the box
so for all of you i have taken this from
an article which is found on the link
below and if you want to go this
approach i would definitely advise you
to get into this because if you're not
familiar with the flux pattern
it takes a bit of time to like grasp the
whole idea behind it it's very powerful
but it's a lot of work and the question
is
do you really need this in your front
end
if you want to have like
the state management kept to a minimum
you might not want to do this
but again i do like the approach so the
idea of the flux pattern is that you are
dealing with immutable
state
you basically use an
action
to
pass in
a change of state
once that state has changed there can be
certain elements certain components that
can register to those
changes on certain states
so the dispatcher will actually make
sure that everybody is notified
that something has changed
and you saw me using
some sort of immutable thing with the
state machine by making their property
read only so the idea is you can only
change state
by calling that dispatcher
passing in
the state change that you want
and it will make sure that nobody else
in your application
illegally can change that state and it
makes you
yeah come up with all kinds of things
that you were not anticipating basically
so
i'm gonna show you i'm not gonna do the
whole live coding thing because it's
it's
a bit much anyway but i will point you
out to how this typically works
and for that i put up another
application and
this application is
in case you forgot how it looked it's
based on the original microsoft template
and
let me see where it will pop up
eventually
was that the right one
no this was the wrong one
i need this one
yeah this is actually the the product
that i have been using was a blazer
server project this is actually a blazer
web assembly one
all right so how does this work well i
have this counter demo
and if i go to the counter
and i click what you'll see is that
there are
two elements being updated the counter
over there and the counter over there
and this is the very basic introduction
on how to apply the flux pattern on your
application
so how how do we approach this well
if we take a look what i first did i
added the the fluxr packages to my
application which are available on nuget
it's free and you can just use it and
there is some good documentation with it
as well
but to give you an idea of the concept
of flux
it works with features and what i've
done is i have created a folder which is
called feature
and in this case i am dealing with the
most simple one which is the counter
the counter feature
has one or more pages so this also
requires a slightly different setup of
the project because you are dealing with
those features and you want to make sure
that you can
find that stuff back again as
well in this case i have this one page
which is the counter
and then
there is the counter store
and the counter store well obviously
there are debates on whether to put
everything in separate files or not but
for this demo i put it all in one file
to give you an idea what is involved
here
the counter
has a state
now what you see here is that i have a
counter state and it has a property
called current count
i did not make this a class but i made
this a record
and why did i do that well a record is
obviously a bit more lightweight but
more important
i can create a copy of a record
instead of a
same reference so if i have object a and
i've got a var b and i say object a b
equals a i'll get a reference to that
same object
while with a record it's going to be a
copy which is excellent for state
and it's way easier as cloning like this
entire object so this is why a record
comes in quite nice
and
i have decorated this current count with
a get
and i'm in
it and the init means
that i can
only
set this current count once i create a
new
entity of this counter state
and the way that that works is
if we check out
we we go down a bit because the feature
is going to be coded in as well
and this is
the feature that this state is providing
basically
this feature is derived from one of the
base classes of the flexor package and
the feature is a generic type so i pass
in that counter state type that's what
we're dealing with
for development purposes i would
certainly give that a i would override
the get name and use the counter and i
will show you in a minute why
and then we have to override the get
initial state so once this thing gets
started it needs to have an initial
state and this is
with the init that i was mentioning on
the record
you uh can pass that initial value like
this
i can't change this anymore and this is
exactly what is important with fluxor we
want immutable state
and this is how you can do that
so the next thing what we need is we
need to define a class
which
defines the action that we want to apply
on this
state and
that action in this case would be the
increment action okay so typically what
happens if i hit that button
it just needs to be a class because this
type is going to be used at runtime to
identify what needs to go so this this
increment action is just like a type
declaration that we need and we can use
that later on
and where do we use that well that's in
this
reducer this reducer class is a static
class it doesn't maintain any state at
all this is very important this is just
a
dumb
class
with a static method inside which is
decorated with the reducer method
and it receives a counter increment
action
and so this is pretty much all the
boilerplate this is what i mentioned
when i started on this you need to
decide whether you need this it's kind
of cool
but it's a lot of stuff that you need to
take care of
but once it runs it's like
yeah technically it's like really cool
so
this on increment what happens here
if that that button is clicked and that
state needs to be incremented
what i'll do
i'll take the current state in that's on
increment
i'll create a copy of it
but i'll increment the copy
i was mentioning earlier with the state
machine i'll return the old value this
is typically the same but this takes it
a step further because what this
actually does
it keeps track of all the state changes
in the
in the flux pattern
so if i click it
the the old state will also be kept
somewhere that's all part of this
package and that makes it quite nice
specifically if you run into issues with
syncing issues and so on you can
actually track that back you can roll
back the state which is
quite cool
and this is also why we were using that
record in the beginning because i can
use this return state width and because
i set the init i can
exactly change it here and nowhere else
right that's the whole idea
all right so this is like the basic
setup for it
and then
if we go back to the page
you can do this on a couple of separate
several ways the first one is
the most easy one
i'll derive my component from the flexor
component
you can also have your own base class
and implement an interface and do a
couple of methods and you can do it
yourself as well but for this we'll just
use the flexor component it will take
care of updating etc etc
i will inject
the state
and it's going to be that counter state
and fluxer takes care of getting the
right thing out of the box
but because i need
to do something with that state by
clicking that button i will also need
that dispatcher
so this is a generic dispatcher
in this case i will get the state out of
this counter state by using this one so
this projects the current count the
state of this counter
and the button will execute the
increment count here
and this will do the following i will
execute the dispatch message on the
dispatcher
by passing in the action that i want to
apply which is the new counter increment
action
and so now the dispatcher will actually
check the
all the code that we have been doing it
will check those reducer methods it will
check the attributes on that et cetera
et cetera and it will find the correct
method in that static class and it will
execute it and this
you didn't see me do any state change
whatsoever that's all been taken care of
by by fluxer
i obviously also did something in the
navigation menu
and the navigation menu i needed to
update that state as well so
what i've hear is
i'm injecting that same state but i
don't need to like change anything so i
don't need a dispatcher i just want to
have that state
and with this particular case i will
update that state just by by doing this
and also i derive the left menu from the
from the flexor component so i don't
need to do a state has changed or
whatsoever that's all been taken care of
by that that base component
and now
yeah what you already saw me do is if i
would actually execute it again
oh
before i execute it again i do want to
show you a couple of things that i have
been setting up
and this is actually one of the cool
things that come with this whole
pattern
you obviously need to tell your
application to use this stuff so what i
have done is um
i have add the fluxer i'm calling the
addfluxer
and i installed the redux dev tools as
well
and i'm configuring it here as well
and so this is how you would set up the
fluxer
state storage
and the only thing you need to do is you
need to pass in the libraries it needs
to scan for your reducer methods and all
the code that is involved all the
boilerplate code basically
and with this in place and particularly
the use redux dev tools i can show you a
really cool trick for with that and for
i'm not sure if i have that installed on
edge so let me open up chrome to make
sure that i have that there
let me pass in the url
and paste this in
all right so here we see the application
and now i'm going to click that all
works and obviously if i go away it will
still be there because that counter is
still five you see so the state will be
available throughout the life cycle of
your application
but now the cool thing is if i open up
the developer tools
and i will go to my uh
what was that again i go to this redux
thing here
this is actually which is
extremely cool because you can actually
see
what is happening here
you can see
what actions have been executed you can
see
what the initial state was it changed
from uh
one to two
you can you can check that state
any anywhere in time which is obviously
for development purposes extremely cool
i've also set up another one uh which is
the fetch data i've done that on the
fluxr as well
i'll go over that code
in a bit because it obviously has a bit
more involved
i didn't do the show celsius versus
fahrenheit because there are a couple of
other things that needs to be taken care
of on this way
can i make this
apparently not
what you will now see is that the
weather forecast action has done
something as well
and the weather forecast data is there
as well you see so you've got some
incredible powerful developer tools to
see where your state has changed why it
changed
and and obviously at run time you want
to disable that but i mean for debugging
this is extremely
nice to have
but again it's it's a bit more work
because if we would take a look at the
weather thing
um that is
done slightly different i mean there is
obviously a couple of things involved
here i've got the page
which is not the exciting part anymore
but the weather store has something else
involved there so here we see that
record again with the data
which holds the state
we have the feature described
and now we have like an initialize then
we have a loading property whether that
data is there
we have an action
and we have the reducer which is a bit
in the same line but what we have also
now
is we have an effect
on this particular
action or a state
and this effect
one of the effects of this is that the
backup needs to be called to get the
data this is not done in the front and
anymore this is all been taken care of
by the fluxer package i mean by defining
this effect to fetch data on the month
is obviously
yeah all
gone away from the ui you don't have
that in there anymore this can be done
asynchronously at any moment in time and
your your ui will still be updated i
mean this is obviously quite
quite nice
yeah but it requires you to think
slightly different
and so we have here the load forecast on
increment and this
this thing can just just used
constructor injection to pass in the
http client it can have the counter
state in there as well
and and and yeah this is how the effect
will like
load in that data here
you see
and well if i would actually
go to the application i on purpose put
in a delay of a second and then i'll
dispatch a message here
that the data has been changed here
so what basically happens if i do that
and i go to the
refresh forecast
this is a separate toaster which was
defined somewhere else but it has been
registered to that to that particular
action
and that will make make it appear as
well so
it's the idea is very good
it's
it's quite complicated and you should
certainly ask yourself
do i need this uh that's that's the
bottom line if you if you're dealing
with like local data storage like you've
got a web assembly
which might be offline for some time you
know when you still need to deal with
data this might be an excellent choice
for you but if you're dealing with like
smaller state stuff
i mean it might be a bit overkill but it
is definitely
worth checking this out i mean
for sure and then the development tools
the redux tools that come with
with chrome is
it's awesome
so
yeah with this i
think that we
uh let me
see where did my slide go actually oh
yeah that was it yeah
yeah
so with this i think i've given you a
couple of options so remember the
cascading state is the most easy one
i guess for a lot of solutions
it's just right now you don't need to
worry too much about this state change
then i mean the elements that actually
changed are being refreshed only you saw
that on the demo
and the second one is the state machine
which is a bit more invisible and it's a
bit more under the hood and you have a
bit more control on
when stuff needs to be updated or
notified or whatsoever
then you have the mvvm pattern and then
obviously you have the flux pattern
and you could have like a combination
you could also apply the mvv and pattern
together with the flux pattern
or you could have the cascading state
together with like a state machine or
whatsoever or you can combine several
things but the last two ones you have to
make up your mind like yeah this is what
we're gonna do
from start from from the start basically
so
yeah with this i am
pretty much done
i hope that i have given you some ideas
if there are any questions
yeah
that's all being dealt with by by uh by
the flexor package basically you saw me
use the add fluxer
method in the startup huh
and that's obviously like an extension
method which is
uh let me see that was right here
yeah so this this at fluxer
method it will actually you'll need to
define the assemblies it needs to scan
at startup and it will find everything
automatically for you
and you don't need to deal with scoped
or whatsoever that's all be taken care
of by flexor
no
nothing to be done there
yeah you can customize quite a bit of
things
yeah but i mean the whole idea about
this is that that fluxr takes care of
the life cycles of your states etc etc
that's that's the whole idea so on one
end you need to do a bit of plumbing and
a bit of code to set it all up
but then at runtime fluxr there's like
uh quite a bunch of things for you
um so yeah that's that's that's a bit uh
how that works basically
so any more questions
yeah
that is yeah that is something you can
use as well but that is obviously
something which is coming from the wpf
world yeah so the i observable
collection eye observable
techniques basically for that you could
you can use that approach as well of
course yeah
that's that's another approach yeah but
in case yeah that is certainly possible
yeah it depends a bit on the on the
requirements of the application i mean
right now i'm i'm i'm working on an
application and i'm you definitely using
the mvvm pattern but there are like
certain data services that i am
implementing the i observable collection
because i need to get notified somehow
if something on that collection changes
so yeah i mean you can have like a few
model where a data service gets injected
and if that data service holds like some
eye observable collection or something
you could actually code something inside
if you model to do something with that
you know it's a bit like
yeah what what the requirements of your
application are i don't have like a
particular thing like don't use it or
use it i mean
use it whenever it saves you time
basically
yeah
yes
yep
yeah
it's it's gonna get big yeah yeah yeah
and i do have to say i have asked a bit
around as well because i was kind of
intrigued by the whole way that this
stuff works actually but the first thing
that i i thought was
this is quite a bit of work to get it's
all together and it's all you have to be
very abstract about you have to see it
in front of you like how am i going to
do that with the actions and stuff it's
a bit of work but the second thing i ask
myself yeah
this is going to take up quite a bit of
memory i guess if you can have like
those states
and the history of states and
i've asked around
apparently people really don't care
about the memory consumption of the
browser or anything i mean i was like
i'm a bit like old school i mean i
started with like a little z80 computer
with machine coding and you know and i
thought like
apparently it doesn't matter so much
these days on the browser
so
i don't know
but i mean all the javascript guys are
using this stuff as well the same
techniques i mean they are pumping your
browser full with like all this stuff so
yeah apparently it works
this will obviously
yeah yeah yeah well
yeah i mean i don't want to i mean
i have the impression that obviously
the more
the younger generation of developers i
mean i don't want to kick anybody
on the on the legs or whatever but
they don't really have an idea on what's
what it takes to do certain things with
the hardware you know
but apparently it works i mean
they
dump everything in the browser and
apparently the browser will
not die for that reason or something but
yeah on the server it will take a load
yeah
but you could actually i mean it's quite
customizable so you could also be like
using
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah maybe you could have like uh
uh what's it called like the the caching
uh service what's it called again i
forgot the name the
the shared caching service which runs on
amazon and on
redis
you could probably
load it off there
yeah
all right
that was it
well thank you very much
if you have any questions afterwards so
whatsoever you can always reach me by my
email address or you can tweet you send
me a tweet or
check out the the first demo the reducer